[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome everyone.
And good morning for those
on the West Coast.
This is Dartisans
Episode Eight.
Welcome to our Dart show.
We broadcast this
live on YouTube.
You can ask questions via our
moderator if you go to
developers.google.com/live.
And we're joined with lots of
great special guests today.
And this will be posted
onto YouTube later,
and also on our podcasts.
So lots of ways to catch up
with the Dart community.
Before we dive into our show, we
have special guests Rikulo,
who are building a UI
framework in Dart.
And we'll chat with some
of the developers.
And we also have special
guests JJ
Behrens and Gilad Bracha.
Hi guys.
And we'll be talking about
some of the latest
developments in the Dart
language spec as we near the
M1 Milestone.
But first let's get started
with some news.
And, as always, a big thanks to
Dartwatch and Chris Bucket
for collecting the weekly news
from the Dart community.
He does a really great job, and
I'm going to share some of
the highlights with you now.
So we've seen a couple
developments with building
games with Dart.
Obviously, games always push
any platform in terms of
performance and capabilities.
And so, of course, when a new
language and system like Dart
comes out, everyone wants to
know how can I build those
really cool games.
So Jacob Deichert, and I hope
I got that last name right,
has updated his Castles game.
And this, and almost all the
libraries that we're going to
be talking about,
are on GitHub.
And all the show notes for all
the news items here are on
Dartwatch.com So Sam McCall, a
Googler, has created a Dart JS
interop library.
This is yet another R&D project
to figure out what's
the right way to integrate the
existing JavaScript libraries
and capabilities with Dart.
We're still trying to feel that
out in exactly what may
be the right way to do that.
So it's great to see different
efforts in this arena.
And you can find this also
on GitHub as well.
Kevin Moore, one of our early
adopters, who's also working
on a proposed canonical layout
for Pub packages, has been
creating QR codes in Dart.
And so that's just a fun little
project from his group.
Bernhard Pichler has been doing
a really cool project
called DartFlash.
Flash.
And he has a blog that has
been started to help
ActionScript 3 developers move
over to Dart, as the languages
are fairly similar.
And I think that the programming
experience is--
I think if you come from
ActionScript 3 you'll find
Dart really pleasurable.
And so he's been working
on what those
libraries look like.
And he also has an open source
game built with DartFlash.
So his work is continuing
as well.
In fact, he has an experimental
particle
animation in DartFlash.
Adam Smith has been--
he always seems to take
out the right commits
at the right time.
He really does a good job
monitoring the change log.
He's found that mirrors are
compiled into the Dart VM.
Now this is an ongoing spec and
implementation effort to
bring reflection-type abilities
to Dart, the run
times and the language.
And so we haven't yet published
much about that.
Things are still in the works,
but it's cool to see that the
teams actively working on the
mirrors and reflection
capabilities.
Brendan Donaldson has been doing
a great job with a lot
of samples about Dart language
and libraries and continues
these on his website,
Dart Examples.
Recently, he's looked at
libraries and interfaces,
which is a little funny because
we're going to be
talking about some of the
changes coming down the pipe
for libraries.
But Brendan is usually pretty
quick at updating all this
stuff, so I'm sure he'll keep
everything up to date.
Adam Smith, again, has put
up a quick guide to
building Dart on Win 32.
In fact, I think Adam and Kevin
were also some the guys
that helped figure out how to
build Dart with Xcode 4.
So it's cool to see more and
more ways to build Dart.
Of course, you can get the
binaries for Dart by
downloading the Dart Editor, but
if you want to play with
the source code and propose
patches to the open source
project, it's nice to know that
you can build on these
different platforms.
Justin Fagnani has created a
Dart-collab sample allowing
you to edit a document
concurrently.
So this is the underlying, basic
technology that things
like Google Docs uses, where
multiple editors on one single
document, more or less in real
time, can collaborate.
And it's really cool to see
some of these low-level
libraries appearing
in Dart as well.
And then this brings us to our
first special guest, Rikulo.
Rikulo, the library for Dart
development on multiple
different form factors,
they've released some
interesting posts, including
a simple snakes game.
And what I like about their
snakes game is that it works
on touch and mouse
and keyboard on
multiple form factors.
And so that's really,
really cool.
So with that, I think, let's
invite our first guest, the
Rikulo team.
And we're going to go
to the Hangout now.
MALE SPEAKER: First of all,
what time is it there?
TIM CLARE: Unfortunately it's
very late or early, depending
on how you want to look at it.
It's actually 10 minutes
past midnight here.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow, you
guys are troopers.
Thanks for joining us.
TIM CLARE: I could
be sleeping.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, where
are you guys again?
TIM CLARE: We're based out
of Taipei, Taiwan.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, that's--
Thank you for staying up late.
I know that Gilad was
complaining about being in
here early.
But we're definitely
global today.
TIM CLARE: Not a problem.
It's our pleasure.
MALE SPEAKER: So you guys want
to go ahead and introduce
yourselves?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, sure.
We'll start with Tim.
MALE SPEAKER: Go ahead, Tim.
TIM CLARE: Sure, I'm actually
the PM, the project manager
for Rikulo.
I was one that did
the snakes game.
I've been working
out [INAUDIBLE]
for approximately
three years now.
So I just generally manage the
day to day runnings of Rikulo
and our community around that.
MALE SPEAKER: And Simon?
SIMON PAI: Yeah, I'm Simon.
I've worked for [INAUDIBLE]
for two years.
And I'm basically one
of the coding guys
behind the Rikulo project.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So why did you guys decide to
use Dart instead of JavaScript
when building Rikulo.
SIMON PAI: One of the major
reason is that we think that
the demand of the client side
programming has been changing.
And, for example, the client
side computing resource is
getting cheaper.
And the application is
getting more complex.
And also, for example, in
mobile pattern it has to
tolerate more offline
situation.
So overall, we demand a more
structured language to support
that kind of complexity
on client side.
And we think Dart fit that
gap pretty well.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh yeah, great.
So your documentation says
that Rikulo uses a
structured UI model.
Can you tell me a little
bit about that?
I kind of almost got the feeling
that you guys were
absolutely positioning all
the elements on the page.
Can you tell me how it's
implemented, like from a
browser perspective?
SIMON PAI: Yeah, pretty much.
Almost all the components are
precisioned absolutely.
But the traditional HTML
layout is still
available as a component.
The reason of doing so is
because CSS-- all those CSS
layout is very powerful.
It has two main types.
You've got this plain block,
inline block in inline
element, floating, and the
alignment, text alignment.
And it's actually OK
when you do this--
when you write an application.
But when it comes to component
design, it will be a nightmare
with those, all those
combinations.
And by making those positioning
absolute, we're
actually making those
things homogeneous.
And it's also very
straightforward, so the user
is easier to predict
the behavior.
And it will introduce
much less block.
MALE SPEAKER: So is this kind
of strongly informed by the
fact that you're trying to build
apps that work mobile,
or would you do this even if
you weren't trying to be
mobile or support mobile?
SIMON PAI: Yeah, Tim, you want
to get a quick question?
TIM CLARE: Yeah--
it's OK, I understand
what you're saying.
Basically, I think it fits into
sort of our vision for a
native mobile and maybe
the future of the web.
It's generally what we would
still be considering because
we see Rikulo as an overall
cross platform.
So for the web, we actually
prefer this
way of doing things.
Basically, this has
come about since--
originally our team, or the
team before us, used to do
Windows desktop development.
And in that, they used to use a
lot of absolute positioning.
And then what we did is, the
team moved on to doing a Java
framework, the Java UI
framework named ZK.
Now within ZK , of course, we
made a lot of uses of CSS.
And, of course, CSS is great,
a very creative website,
laying out positions of your
website to such things as big
magazines, creating
flashy interfaces.
But ZK's focus was particularly,
like
applications for enterprise.
So within applications for
enterprise, you wanted a more
desktop feel to that.
So we found that when you use
CSS, it really pushed the
limits of what it's meant to
do, when you have layouts
within layouts within layouts,
when you wanted to
build up your UI.
And that led to fringe
case bugs.
So, in this case, we've come
back to sort of the beginning,
as you will, and come back to
the structured UI model that
Simon's just stated, with
absolute positioning.
And also some relative
positioning
aspects of it as well.
MALE SPEAKER: I think this is a
testament to the performance
of modern browsers.
I think that I've seen some
other approaches that-- just
computing the position of all
the elements in code.
And I'm shocked at how fast that
these browsers can do it.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, you know,
it's amazing if you think like
5, 10 years ago, no one would
have done this, because it
would have made it dog slow.
But with V8, it's now possible
to do all these things in
JavaScript.
It's amazing.
MALE SPEAKER: I'd love to hear
a little bit about what are
some of the features of Dart
that have been particularly
beneficial to you
guys, as you've
built out this framework.
What are some of the
capabilities that you're
really exploiting to
get the job done?
SIMON PAI: Oh like one of the
best uses we have in Dart is
it both has class and closure.
So it exposes more options
to help us to
decide our API design.
MALE SPEAKER: That's one
of my favorites.
Yeah, the classes
versus closures.
That's one of those
things like tastes
great versus less filling.
Remember those commercials?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I think
what they're saying what I
love about Dart is I get both.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: I get
the lexical scope.
I get closures.
I get classes.
And I get top level functions,
and so I don't have to
completely adopt only
one of those models.
Any time it feels natural to
use one of them, I can.
And in Dart, it works
altogether.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
SIMON PAI: Yeah, I think it's
more like twice finally
[INAUDIBLE], a chance to define
your concept in Dart
compared to Java.
MALE SPEAKER: So any time I talk
to people doing mobile
applications, I always
love to ask, what
percentage do you think--
a lot of applications these days
are a mix of native code
as well as web code,
using web views.
And so I always ask, what
percentage is native, and what
percentage is web?
And where do you think we're
going to go in the future, a
few years, maybe two
years from now?
Do you think that percentage
is going to change?
And what kind of percentages do
you use in your own code?
TIM CLARE: OK, at the moment--
let's, for example, use snake.
The snake code, I'm actually
going to be changing it for
more mobile focus.
At the moment, like you said,
yes you can use mouse.
You can use touch gestures.
But one of the things that
we're going to change--
we're going to play with, is
making so snake can be
controlled using the alignment
of the phone.
So you tilt it and it
will move the snake.
That is going to be one of the
demos that we're doing.
So, generally, to come back to
your question and answer that.
Where we see it going is just
enough so you can make use of
the native mobile functionality,
because that is
really the major difference
between doing everything in
the web and doing everything
natively, is the actual
functions of the phone.
MALE SPEAKER: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: To us, that's
the only limitation that
you've got.
So we see that mobile is going
to go the way of, maybe in the
future, of being able to access
these directly from the
browser, maybe.
In the future as well, because
we sort of focus on mobile as
one of our primary goals,
but definitely we also
looked at the web.
And actually, Rikulo has a
framework within Dart for web
development and creating
websites.
In addition, in the far future,
as well, just going
way off into the future, we're
looking at the possibility of
maybe the Dart VM actually
is very powerful.
So maybe in the very future,
that can actually be ported to
Android itself.
So any application you do Rikulo
is natively running on
your Android phone.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, both Android
and Dart are open
source, and I think some
enterprising young fellow in
the open source community
might-- it'll be an
interesting experiment to see
if that could happen.
But, I think, this does
bring up a good point.
You mentioned the Dart VM.
But we keep talking about Dart
and Rikulo and mobile.
I think it's important to
point out that you're
compiling your Dart code to
JavaScript via the Dart to JS
compiler that ships with the
Dart SDK and Editor.
And this allows any Dart app
to run on all the modern
browsers out there.
Talk a little, about a minute,
about your experience using
Dart to JS and compiling
to JavaScript.
How's that working for you?
TIM CLARE: With regard to the
snake game, I think if you go
on to the blog for Rikulo you
can actually see that we've
embedded the snake game directly
into the web browser.
And personally what I've found
is it's very good.
I had absolutely no problems
compiling to JavaScript and
running it in my Firefox
browser, in Chrome,
et cetera, et cetera.
I also liked the fact that
with our system and the
structured UI that sorts of
Simon was talking about, it's
very easy to get a nice looking
interface up and running.
So, again, the snake game that
you see tries to mimic the
old-style Nokia phone game.
I don't know whether
you've seen that.
So that's what we
try and mimic.
So, all in all, I'd say the
experience of compiling to JS
and running it in
the browser has
been pretty much fantastic.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So another one that's kind of
interesting these days is, how
do you guys do testing?
It's not always so easy to
test apps in the browser.
I mean, there's unit test
libraries, but how do you do
testing in terms of testing your
code, but also testing
the appearance and user
functionality across browsers
and devices?
SIMON PAI: We have
to [INAUDIBLE]
our testing mechanisms
for Rikulo.
But we aiming for the automation
testing, like using
[INAUDIBLE].
And we have lots of experience
on that from our previous
products [INAUDIBLE].
And I think its achievable
to do to such approach.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
And then [INAUDIBLE], I was
reading through your
documentation, and it kind of
seemed like it really had kind
of an Android feel to the API.
I was like, wow, this looks
really, really familiar.
Can you guys tell me what are
the different projects that
inspired Rikulo.
TIM CLARE: Sure.
It actually goes back to
what I said earlier.
The first inspiration came
from the Windows desktop
development model and all the
desktop development models for
the absolute positioning.
And then we learned from our
experience from ZK and CSS to
position and it'll come back
to that, absolutely, with
layout paradigm.
In addition, we did look
at Android quite a lot.
A lot of our people in-house
have good experience with
Android and, of course, iOS.
So it made sense to
look at it there.
See what APIs were available.
In addition, as well, because
of the power of the Dart
language, we're looking at sort
of the API of the Dart.
So this is just a good
opportunity for me to say that
we appreciate all contributions
to Rikulo, not
just code, not just
documentation.
By that what I mean is people
just using Rikulo and then
giving their thoughts on
the API that we've
got around with Rikulo.
Seeing whether we can fit in
more Dart features, whether we
missed something, whether
someone thinks something is
more elegant.
We're totally open to
all those feedback.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
MALE SPEAKER: And on that note,
I think, as we wrap up,
what is some of your feedback
to the Dart team?
I always like to hear what are
some of the things that you'd
like us to be working on
next to help Rikulo.
SIMON PAI: To be honest, our
top request is definitely
looking forward to the following
release of the first
official version of Dart.
We think Dart is a great
language and it's getting
greater every day.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
That's good feedback.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, how
can people try Rikulo?
And what do you want to
ask everyone to do?
TIM CLARE: Personally, I'd just
like to ask everybody to
download it.
Try the samples.
If you take a look at our
Google+ page, there's
information on getting started
with the samples.
You can also download Snake.
Give that one a go.
And any feedback--
I'm not a games developer,
so there's probably
some mess in there.
So if you've got any feedback
on improving the sample,
that'd be great for
me to hear.
And, really just give Rikulo a
try, and just feedback through
us by email or something
like that.
We are very open to suggestions,
and we're very
open to contributors getting
involved us.
MALE SPEAKER: And what's
the website again?
TIM CLARE: It is
www.rikulo.org.
MALE SPEAKER: You want
to spell that?
TIM CLARE: That is
R-I-K-U-L-O.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thanks.
Awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: So we're going to
do next talk to Gilad, and
I know he wants to show us the
proposed syntax for imports,
but we're going to have to cut
off the Hangout right now.
MALE SPEAKER: We're going
to bye and thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: We're
going to goodbye.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's right.
And then do sharing
the screen.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we're going
to flip over to Gilad in
talking about some of the--
So thanks, guys, of Rikulo.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, guys.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
for staying up late.
That's awesome.
And with that, yeah let's talk
to our next special guest,
Gilad Bracha.
And thanks for joining
us this morning.
GILAD BRACHA: Hey Seth, sorry.
My machine logged me out.
MALE SPEAKER: That's OK.
As everyone knows, we are
gearing up for an n1 line in
the sand, if you will,
around the language.
And that lets our
implementations then buckle
down and all get up to the same
state, and then focus on
other cool things like
performance and
libraries, et cetera.
But to do all that, we've got
to get the n1 language
comfortable.
And one of the big pieces of
feedback we've received from
all the major hackathons we've
done, and mailing list
feedback and bugs, et cetera,
is people are--
developers are asking for a
better way to compose their
libraries together, both an
easier-to-understand syntax
but I think just easier to
understand mental model.
And so it was awesome.
The team went back and huddled
and came up with--
I'm really impressed, some
really great changes that, to
me at least, answered some
of my biggest questions.
And here to explain the
libraries and import syntax
and semantics and just changes
coming down, Gilad.
So, thanks.
GILAD BRACHA: OK.
So I guess people can
see what we have--
MALE SPEAKER: Do we need
to share the screen?
GILAD BRACHA: --on the screen.
MALE SPEAKER: I think we need
to share the screen.
MALE SPEAKER: We're good.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, we're good.
Wow.
All right.
GILAD BRACHA: So this is sort
of a dummy example I just
typed in here a few
minutes ago.
But people who are already
familiar with the library
syntax that we have right now
will notice a few changes.
And some of them are
just cosmetic.
And there always are a lot
of comments on syntax.
But, more substantially really,
there were some issues
with the library design, where
we wanted to make it more
robust, in terms of how
libraries evolve.
We wanted to make it a bit
easier for people to use in a
few cases where they complained
about issues.
And so there are a number of
actually meaningful semantic
features that are
different here.
So, as you can see, the
hash marks are gone.
You don't--
let's see, actually some of
these things actually were
specced one way and
never implemented.
And now they're specced
another way.
So you probably don't even
realize some of the
improvements that we made.
But the basic idea here is still
that libraries can be
broken into different parts.
But one of the big changes is
we formalized this notion of
parts, because people were quite
uncomfortable with this
idea that you just use the
source directive and sucked in
some code into a library.
This gave some people
the willies.
They were thinking of
like preprocessors
and stuff like that.
And we didn't help this by
having this hash syntax, which
we thought would be familiar but
turned out to give people
the wrong association, because
it never really worked, like
includes and things like that.
MALE SPEAKER: You know, I kept
trying to type #ifdef and it
wasn't working.
I don't understand.
GILAD BRACHA: Well, I'm glad
at least that didn't work.
But the idea here is
now that there--
that you can still break your
library into parts.
But one of the key things was
that there wasn't a real
connection between the parts and
the library, or, at least,
there was only a one
way connection.
A library mentioned what things
it was sourcing in.
But whatever you were sourcing
in was just a file somewhere
that could go anywhere.
And this caused issues
in terms of--
OK, you go browse this source.
What's the context now, because
the scope is actually
influenced by--
is the whole library
wide scope?
So everything else
in the library
should be visible there.
But how do you know that?
How do your tools know that?
And so, we got to-- we decided
that the parts actually have
to point back at the library.
Well, have is strong word,
because there are cases where
you don't want it.
But let's--
I'm going to just--
let's suppose this is a
different file now.
Oops, sorry.
Shift right we'll just put
a line in the sand here.
And you're going to have--
suppose this is like the ABC.
And so, in ABC, we might say
something like part of my lib.
So there's basically-- the
individual parts declare that
they are part of something.
So there's a connection.
So they don't belong to
something random.
And that gives everyone, the
user, the tools, the sort of
information they need.
Now, nothing is ever that
simple, because, for example,
for testing we actually rely
on the fact that you can
actually plug things into
different libraries.
And so what happens is that you
can still refer to a part
from multiple libraries.
And A, if your testing library
simply has the same name,
you'll be good.
If for some reason your
testing library has a
different name, or you have
found some other exotic case
where you really wanted to share
this stuff, you'll get a
warning
Dart's philosophy is generally
to slap you gently rather than
kick you in the gut,
as the bondage and
discipline school suggest.
And so, it'll still work.
But yeah, if you can tolerate
the warning
then you can do that.
But we generally recommend
that a part belongs to a
particular library or, at most,
to a library and its
test cousin.
MALE SPEAKER: So you have my
lib here as the identifier,
the name of the library.
Is that any relation
to the file name
now or is that separate?
GILAD BRACHA: It doesn't
have to be related.
It might be very sensible to do
have a convention where it
was related.
But it doesn't have to be.
It's an identifier.
The identifier--
people kept asking why is there
a library name in the
first place?
And kept telling them,
eventually you're going to
want to reflect on these
things, print them out,
there's all kinds of reasons.
But all of this was abstract
since the mirror stuff
wasn't there yet.
One more reason now is this
gives you something you can
name in the parts.
This is how you refer to the
library from the part.
And you want a name, as opposed
to the URI, because
you don't want to have to
reconfigure these things every
time something moves.
So that's one set of
important changes.
The other set of important
changes really have to do with
imports, the stuff
that's up here--
imports, and the hide and show
operators, and how we do
prefixes, and stuff.
Well, which looks rather
different--
lot of people wanted a quote
"real syntax." Now I wanted a
real syntax.
The original idea of the syntax
was to make it look
like a reflective call, with the
intention of building this
reflective library interface
that would be
familiar at that point.
But turns out that there's a
reason people have syntax.
And reflective calls are
a bit harder to use.
So we've gone to a more
conventional syntax, which
does look nicer.
And gets rid of the hash
which confuses
the hell out of people.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, aren't you
worried that, with this new
syntactic sugar, that syntactic
sugar will lead to
cancer of the semicolon?
I
GILAD BRACHA: This is not really
sugar, in the sense
that this is simply expressing
what you wanted to do.
Now I can give you lots of
examples in Dart where it
already is tempting people.
And people need a
semi-colonoscopy to
overcome that.
But--
MALE SPEAKER: Touche.
GILAD BRACHA: in this case,
I don't think we've gone
overboard at all.
We're basically--
we've gotten rid of noise,
right, hash, the parens.
All the things that are
necessary to parse a general
purpose expression.
But aren't necessary, in the
case, where you actually know
what we're doing here.
So, it's just lighter.
And there is more important,
right-- people
focus on the syntax--
but more important is it
semantically there are
important differences here
that make libraries more
robust in the face of long-term
software evolution,
which is one of our big
goals with Dart.
And we're just starting this,
because Dart hasn't been
around much.
People haven't yet encountered
all the troubles that have
led, say, to all these
complicated practices and
tools and save the Java
world, et cetera.
So the need for serious library
management is only
beginning to surface.
But, here inside the Dart team,
we've already hit some
of these issues.
And so we're trying to make
that more robust.
MALE SPEAKER: Can you talk a
little bit more about what
hide show and that and
exports syntax?
MALE SPEAKER: Right, perfect.
That is exactly how we make
these things more robust.
So one issue is, a big issue, of
course, is conflicts among
your imports.
And so we're trying to give
you tools for name space
management.
So really what you're importing
isn't, strictly
speaking, a library.
You're importing a name space.
And it used to be that you
imported the library, and you
got its entire main space.
And, if they conflicted, well
there's a problem, which means
that, over time, as library A
adds something, they might
break their clients because
somehow there's a conflict.
So we've done several things
to do ameliorate that.
One thing is that the
definitions inside your
library, the importer, always
take precedence
over anything important.
So no one can break
you that way.
If you have a name, and
they have a name,
your name always wins.
That makes things a
bit more robust.
Then there's a question
of what happens.
OK.
So I'm importing two libraries
that happened to have a
conflict between them.
So we've--
used to be that we complained
sort of eagerly in the fail
fast tradition.
We said, OK, there's
a conflict here.
Now we only complain, well not
now, when this is implemented,
we will only complain if you're
actually using a member
that's ambiguous, that comes
in from multiple places.
MALE SPEAKER: And that makes
a lot of sense, because if
you're importing two third party
libraries, and you don't
want to see any warnings, that
would be really irritating to
see a warning that you
have no control over.
GILAD BRACHA: Right.
And even more irritating where
you get a compile time error,
which is actually [INAUDIBLE]
state now.
This is possible with libraries
as opposed to, for
example, inheritance and
stuff like that.
I'm not going to
get into that.
But there's good reasons why
sometimes you don't do it in
the sort of situations
that seem similar.
So all of these things kind of
help to help libraries evolve
independently without breaking
their clients.
In addition, we have these hide
and show operators that
basically let you control
the name space.
So maybe, in fact, I'd recommend
you use these left
and right, but most people
are too lazy.
One of the things people have
learned in the Java world is
that blanket imports are
actually bad style.
And you want to import
individual elements.
This, in a way, gives you
a way to do that.
So the show combinator, if you
look at the third line along
the imports over here, basically
says, OK, I'm going
to import from baz.dart, but the
only things I want are the
name things.
So these are names of classes
or top level functions,
basically top level members
of the library.
And so you can actually control
exactly what you want
to see, which, again, reduces
the risk of any conflict, and
lets you decide which one
you wanted to use,
and things like that.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you think that
one day, maybe in the
distant future, the Dart Editor
will automatically
manage those so that you know
exactly where things are
coming from?
GILAD BRACHA: I'm pretty sure.
And I don't think it should
be that distant, right?
This is, indeed, one of
the reasons, right?
So wildcard imports, as in most
languages, are motivated
by that great force programmer
laziness.
And the only way to--
it doesn't help to write-- style
guys would say, well you
really should import each one
individually, so you really
know exactly what your
dependencies are.
That's all good and true.
But it's like dieting, people
lack character.
And so, this is sort of
a dieting machine.
The ID, which sort of says, I'll
figure out what you're
actually using and put these
things in for you.
And that's quite common in, I
think, now in the Java world?
And it's a small matter
of programming.
The Dart Editor team is doing
a terrific job of trying to
catch up with 10, 20 years of
work in other tools have
behind them, to give you
that experience.
And they've made very great
strides in the past year.
And I imagine that it won't be
all that long, once this
construct is in there and
implemented, and the compiler
and stable, and we know how to
use it, they'll probably start
supporting that.
So, in fact, maybe-- again, it's
also a policy decision--
but I would encourage people
to say import and then show
each individual thing
that you're using.
MALE SPEAKER: Now there's two
ways, I think, to hide names.
You can use the underscore,
or you can use Hide.
What are some of the pros
and cons of that?
GILAD BRACHA: There are
more than two ways.
And it depends what Hide
means as various
great men have said.
So hiding via under
bar is privacy.
That means the language
basically makes them invisible
outside the library.
That's sort of good
from a software
engineering point of it.
You control the fact, you as a
library author, control the
fact that nobody can
touch the stuff.
That's library-based privacy.
That's one mechanism.
The mechanisms you see
here are in the
hands of the importer.
So the person outside the
library is importing.
He can control the name space
that they're bringing in.
And there are actually three
ways to control this.
So Show is one of them, which
says explicitly, I want this
and this and that, and then all
the rest isn't coming in
through this particular
import.
Another one is Hide, which says,
well, you know what, I
still have no character.
I want everything, except
this one or two,
which actually conflict.
And I want to filter them out.
So Hide is sort of symmetric
to Show.
And then there's As, which is
the third line, which is what
was currently called
the prefix, right?
So, basically, when we say
import bam.dart as bam, that's
essentially introducing
a prefix.
So all the names coming in from
bam.dart are going to be
prefixed by bam.
So you'll say bam.x and bam.y.
MALE SPEAKER: That also seems
like a pretty safe approach.
GILAD BRACHA: Yeah that's true,
though it does tend to
make your names more verbose.
And so, I'm not sure how--
we're still giving
people options.
The other thing that's subtle,
and important to note, is that
the name space, the stuff that
you are bringing in, you
sometimes want to also expose
it to your clients.
Right?
So this was, I think, this
is less of a problem.
But at the stage, you guys
remember this probably in more
detail than I do.
What we used to have-- dart
dot Dart going HTML.
And they were similar.
And people wanted bits of both
and they conflicted, and it
was very hard to manage.
And you sort of well, A, being
able to selectively control
this is one thing that helps.
But it also is true that you
might think of creating a
library that just had the mix of
things that you wanted, and
bringing that in and then
exporting it out.
In fact, you can--
it helps you build smaller
libraries, right, because you
can actually have a library that
has no real content, in
itself, but is sort
of a funnel.
You're piping in several
components.
And, say, well you're always
going to want to go on HTML,
and SVG, or whatever, So some
combination that goes together.
That doesn't mean they have to
be lobbed together in this
giant monster.
You import them and
re-export them.
And that's what the
and export is.
And JJ and others have
complained about the syntax,
always complain about syntax.
MALE SPEAKER: So sorry.
MALE SPEAKER: You have
to give them
something to complain about.
Whatever syntax you have,
misdirect them
from the real problem.
GILAD BRACHA: Exactly.
Yes.
It's actually fairly--
we considered a number of
combinations with this thing.
And we sort of wanted that
import declaration to flow.
And it's important that export
shouldn't be in the wrong
place, because you don't
export the prefixes.
Right?
Because the prefix is
your own problem.
You as a library want
to control your
internal name space.
You want to give it this name.
But letting that flow outward,
when you re-export, you've
started getting very long,
qualified names and conflicts
with other people just choosing
the same prefix.
So you don't actually want
to export the prefix.
So what you're exporting is a
name space that hasn't had
this prefix applied to it.
And so, you can't necessarily
put the export in front of the
As because then it feels
like you're renaming.
The exported name spaces
includes the prefix.
So it's tricky.
And I'm sure I'll be flooded
with suggestions on the other
things, some of which
we've considered.
A lot of people suggested
well have a
separate export directive.
The problem with that is that
it makes you repeat yourself
which is not a popular thing.
Because you not only repeat the
name of the library or the
URI or whatever, but because you
may be importing this with
all these high directives or
whatever, then there's more
stuff that you are going
to have to say again.
And so you really want to tie
the export to the importer.
And re-export the name space
that a given import does.
MALE SPEAKER: You know, It's
kind of interesting looking at
that ampersand.
It reminds me of when we
had the pound import.
And it's like, oh, why
am I having strange
flashbacks to C?
It's like I think I'm doing
bitwise operators here.
GILAD BRACHA: Right, but this is
actually, well we could do
double ampersand and it
would be logical.
But no seriously, we could do
introducing lots of keywords
is always problematic.
Are they real keywords?
Are they pseudo keywords?
Are they none of the above?
The less words we have to
introduce, the better.
And, on the other hand,
we wanted this to flow
as a sort of phrase.
Import this and export it.
Otherwise, export just sits
there and it also looks weird.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, we've got
a couple minutes left.
And we have some questions
from the public.
So let's take a couple
of these.
So Ladislav , a guy who's
doing a great job
participating in the mailing
list, wants to know-- he
acknowledges that libraries are
identified by arbitrary
strings and [INAUDIBLE]
what to a
qualified identifier here.
But is the way of locating the
libraries for import also
going to change?
GILAD BRACHA: There's no
plan for doing that.
There are a lot of people
who are fond of URIs.
Given that we only have a few
minutes, I won't give a long
discourse on the history of this
idea, of starting with
Modula and [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff like that.
It could be done that
way, right?
You could have just mentioned
the name and the environment
We'd have to integrate more
tightly into the language so
it would go find
things for you.
This is largely what--
with more retarded things in
public-- but very basic tools
were built into compilers, that
you'd name a module that
you were importing, and it would
generally look in the
directory where it was
installed, or have a path.
We're not doing that.
This makes it easy to set
up things initially.
And it probably isn't
going to change.
MALE SPEAKER: I think has an
echo to our web programming
backgrounds, where you
can just pull in by
files in URIs together.
And quickly get started
without having this
infrastructure that large.
I think that something
to do with it.
Kevin asks, I think this is a
nice perspective question.
What was the thinking behind
library-based privacy instead
of object-based privacy?
GILAD BRACHA: Ouch.
MALE SPEAKER: In two
minutes please.
MALE SPEAKER: I don't think
this is very loaded.
I think it's a curiosity.
GILAD BRACHA: No, no.
I like object-based privacy.
The thing is, object-based
privacy is--
it's an austere discipline.
Right?
It requires you to design.
It makes certain kinds
of things hard.
When you have multiple classes
that are interoperating, you
want to-- there are objects to
flow out of the library and be
accessed, but you don't want
them to expose their API.
But they, between themselves,
have to operate.
And it can get fairly tricky
how to do that.
You put some shared state hidden
in the library and have
them talk through that.
It gets rather messy.
It is a lot easier to work with
library-based privacy,
but it does create certain weird
situations that I'm not
fond of but--
Language design is
a compromise.
MALE SPEAKER: There's a couple
of questions I think are easy
answer, but are great.
I think a lot of people
have them.
What is the status of the
official Dart UI Library?
And how might web components
factor in?
This is from Kevin.
This is a great question.
The team's still hard at work
trying to figure out how the
new features, the web platform,
web components,
impact and affect a
Dart UI library.
And so the team's hard
at work on that.
It's still very much part
of the road map.
But it remains to be seen
exactly how they're going to
play together.
But I can say it's fair to
assume that the Dart UI
Library will play well with web
components as they grow
and become better
specced out and
implemented across browsers.
Polix asks, are there plans for
a global pub repository?
If yes, will it be a repository
of source files or
a global map from library name
to Git repositories or both?
There is a plan for, hopefully,
many different,
global pub repositories.
I know the Dart team will
stand up their own,
pub.dartlink.org, which will
be probably the first, but
hopefully not the only, package
repository that the
Pub command works from.
I don't know
exactly what's going happen.
I believe the idea is it will
be friendly to both source
code repositories like Git,
as well as [? Tarjeezy ?]
snapshots.
So I think, at least, we'll have
those two mechanisms to
publish out your packages and
upload metadata and find and
discover and install packages.
And then, I think, another good
question from Polix is--
is there an easy way to
obtain a Dart REPL?
If not, are there any plans
to provide one?
This
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GILAD BRACHA: This should have--
this should have been
there from day one.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, so
you like REPLs.
GILAD BRACHA: Well, REPLs
are a first step.
REPLs are actually-- it's sad
that we're talking about REPLs
when we can actually go a good
way beyond REPLs, right?
Try it on the Dartlang.
When it was being put up, I
sort of screamed that this
should at least be a
REPL if not more.
But there were technical
difficulties
around it or whatever.
It didn't happen.
I think that the tools
should offer you more
than a REPL, right?
The ability to, not only execute
these things, but to
then inspect their results as
to an object inspector.
And there's lots of cool
examples of that in the list
and smalldoc worlds and
stuff like that.
And this will happen.
It annoys me more than
it annoys you, how
slowly this is happening.
But mirrors will make
some of that easier.
And just hold your breath
turn blue and--
MALE SPEAKER: It'll
eventually happen.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah I come
from the Python and Ruby
background.
And so I definitely
feel a little bit
strange not having REPL.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
we're out of time.
So I want to thank our special
guest, Rikulo.
Thanks guys, for staying
up again.
And Gilad, thank you very much
for getting up early and
helping explain the new library
imports [INAUDIBLE]
syntax.
I think this is going to be big
boon, especially when Pub
and the new library stuff,
we're going to see an
explosion of third
party libraries.
I want to encourage everyone
to join us
on the mailing list.
The [INAUDIBLE]
That's the general discussion.
And certainly encourage
everyone to ask their
questions on Stack Overflow.
I think the tag is just
the keyword Dart.
And you'll find us, as well as
others from the community,
answering questions and just
generally helping out and
being really friendly.
I love to see the community
participate,
and so lots of ways.
And, finally, a call
for feedback.
Just generally love to see
what you're building.
We love to know what you
think and what you use.
And what you'd like to see us
help you to make the world's
next awesome modern web app.
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
MALE SPEAKER: So with that,
thanks everybody.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: And we'll see you
next time on Dartisans.
Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]